Hey guys, what is up? Faiz here. So this is the very first video of the course update. Actually I had all the videos ready, but unfortunately my windows got corrupted for some reason. Like I put it up my computer. I went to the login screen. I typed in my password and it just won't let me log in. So I had to reinstall the windows and all the data was like gone, poof. So this is me remaking these videos once again. Alright, so
We use volume imbalance for our entries.
Okay, most of the time.
And we can also use them as support and resistance levels.
Institutional support and resistance levels.
Now what is a volume imbalance?
It is a difference between a close and the open.
It is a gap between the close and the open of the candle.
So in this example, you can see this candle right here, it closed right here.
And the next candle, instead of opening at the closing price, it opens below the
closing price, leaving this imbalance or volume imbalance around here.
Now this is a two pattern, two candle pattern.
Okay, so so this volume imbalance occurs between two candles. Okay, so you can see right here the candle closed here
and the next candle instead of opening at the closing price of the previous candle it opens just below it
Right, so there was so much volume that the candle just you know opened here. So the gap
Right from the close to the open
is what you call a volume imbalance.
Okay, sorry for that.
And the over here for the long example,
the difference or the gap between the close
and the open of the next candle is called volume imbalance.
I'm going to repeat this again.
You can see this down candle closed here
and normally what would happen is the next candle
the standard would open from the closing price of the previous candle.
But when this happens, the next candle opens below the closing price of the previous candle,
or above the closing price of the previous candle,
the gap between the opening and close is what you call volume imbalance.
So in the future, if price comes back into this level, you can look for long positions.
Okay?
And similarly for this.
Sorry, this is a short position.
So you can look too short.
Okay?
And yeah, you can long from here as well because this X as a resistance and support level.
level. So if the volume imbalance is broken, that if the support resistance level is broken,
it's going to turn into support, right? So let's say price comes back, gives a small
direction, pushes up, and then you can take this volume imbalance as a support level,
then you can look for longs, just like support and resistance. Okay? But these are very
stronger than support and resistance, normal support and resistance. And sometimes I even
find them more powerful than we were able to get. So let me give you guys some
examples. So right here you can see I'm looking at E-mini S&P on a daily time
frame and one thing I also use volume imbalance to identify my daily bias, okay?
Not all the time but if it is at a you know a clear volume imbalance area
then I can take my decision. However, let's talk about this. So you can see right
here, let me remove this, the candle closes here and the next candle opens right
here. Okay, so there is this gap or volume, no, this is not gap, this is volume
imbalance. Okay, and you can see price came into this volume imbalance. First of
for it just smash through this level.
So this didn't work as a support level.
Okay, very cool.
But then when it gets broken,
it can react as a resistance level.
So price went back to this volume imbalance
and you can see price shot down.
Now over here, you can see we have another volume imbalance.
So the candle closed here, right?
And the next candle open here instead of opening from here.
Okay?
And what you're gonna see here is this right here,
a volume imbalance just right here.
And what happens?
Price matches through it, right?
It didn't work as a support level.
But then in the future, it became a resistance level.
and price couldn't go above this level.
So when price came into this level,
you could be bearish as hell for the next one, two, three, four,
five days, guys, until this, this liquid level was taken up.
Okay.
Over here, you can see, just like that,
we have volume imbalance.
Price came back into this level.
We had a short reaction.
Over here, we have volume imbalance as well.
price came down, boom.
Over here, we have volume imbalance.
Price came down, boom.
And over here, you can see, it didn't exactly
tapped into the volume imbalance, I believe.
OK, it did actually.
So it came back again, tapped perfectly
into this volume imbalance.
Also considered in the fact that we had order block here.
So that is another confluence.
And you can see we have this old volume imbalance,
price pushed up, came back into this volume imbalance.
So you see how this works as support and resistance levels.
Pushes back up again.
Then we have this volume imbalance.
And let me do this.
Yep, you can see it reacted off this level here.
Price went back here, smashed through this level.
Then we have old imbalance here, volume imbalance.
Price came back into this level.
We have a push up, then we have this imbalance,
volume imbalance, price came back,
a little bit of liquidation here,
and then pushed back up, right?
This old volume balance, price came back here.
So you see how accurate these levels are.
And you can see this old volume imbalance right here,
if I drag this along,
you can see that the price is now reacting of this level.
So this is the beauty of volume imbalance.
you mostly find volume imbalances on futures indices.
You can find them on Forex as well,
but I would suggest that you use this with indices, okay?
I'm not saying that you cannot use with Forex,
but of course, yeah.
So normally I would not use volume imbalances
when training my strategies for entries, okay?
But for daily bias, and yeah,
You can look for entries you're using volume of balance too.
It's just like frame of gap.
Actually stronger than frame of gap.
But sometimes it's hard to spot these levels.
But let's assume that if I have a volume of balance here,
at this old level, let's do this.
So we have volume of balance.
And we also have some frame of gap here.
Now that is a double confidence.
So then I can look to take my entry here.
But you can just enter a volume of balance by itself.
Okay.
So you guys, I hope this video was clear.
And I hope you guys know what a volume of balance is.
It looks something like this where you have a,
you know, a close,
and then the open is actually from here.
You can see candle close here.
Open is right here.
So, I'll see you guys in the next video.